forget about the supreme court the
presidential
race has now completely shifted and it
has
shifted because of the court because
president trump nominated
amy coney barrett now we gather in the
rose garden
to continue our never ending task
of ensuring equal justice and preserving
the impartial
rule of law today it is my honor to
nominate
one of our nation's most brilliant and
gifted legal minds
to the supreme court she is a woman
of unparalleled achievement towering
intellect
sterling credentials and unyielding
loyalty to the constitution judge
amy coney barrett
i do not know how amy coney barrett is
going to rule on
any particular case that's not the point
i do know that the glorious acb
is the single best chance that president
trump
has being re-elected and that is for two
major reasons
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from thursday from wes
brown says i'm always confused as to why
the clips you use of slow joe have him
speaking
in a perfectly normal tone and cadence
then i remember that i'm listening
at 1.75 speed oh that'll do it that's
true you think
everything else is speeding around you
know going a mile a minute and then
joe biden is speaking in a slightly slow
but still a little more
uh intentional cadence but no that's
because you've sped them up almost
2x you know this presidential
race this supreme court
uh filling they are very complicated
uh we're going to get through all the
little things that are so complicated
about it what it means how one interacts
with the other but they're very
complicated you know what doesn't have
to be complicated
shopping for auto parts that's what and
that's why i want to thank our friends
over at rockauto rockauto.com
is a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
best thing of all rockauto.com prices
are reliably low they're the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
and believe it or not even i can
navigate their website
i don't know anything about cars i can
barely change my oil
especially when you look into a car and
you see you've got this gizmo over here
in this computer over here
even i can navigate that catalog you can
quickly figure out which parts are
available
for your vehicle you can choose the
brands the specs the prices
that you prefer and i love it's not
gimmicky it's not like and you've got to
buy this now and this price and this and
then the other thing no
always reliably low family run business
head on over right now to
rockauto.com you can check out all those
parts available for your car
or truck then write knowles canon w l e
s
in there how did you hear about xbox and
they will know that we sent you and you
will be able to navigate the website
because even i can
president trump officially nominates
judge
amy coney baron did you hear what he
said there when he nominated her he
didn't say and she's going to be a
fighter and she's going to rule the way
we want her to rule all the time and
she's going to
pass legislation for the bench i mean
usually the left isn't that obvious
about it
but they do say these things she's a
fighter she's standing up for this she's
standing for that
talking about judges as though they're
activists and politicians
trump didn't do that he said she's going
to ensure justice she's going to be
impartial she's going to follow the law
and the left is now saying no she won't
she's a threat to the constitution she
could never be
impartial and what's funny about that
line of attack that you're hearing
we'll get into a few lines of attack
that they're using right now on the
glorious acb
but what's funny about that one is
they're attacking her for not being
impartial and for not supporting the
constitution
when the left doesn't believe in
impartiality
and they certainly don't believe in the
constitution but even just that idea of
impartiality they don't believe in that
right
they're denying the idea that you can be
outside of your own interests
outside of your own biases they do this
on race
they do this on sex they do this on all
sorts of grievance that's the point of
intersectionality
that's the point of all this grievance
mongering and saying we can't
actually access justice we can't
actually communicate about objective
reality
all we can do is express our own
interests and desires and
if you you know if you're a white man
you need to shut up and you can't have
your opinions anymore and if you don't
have this
lived experience then you can't have an
opinion about it so there's
the idea of impartiality doesn't exist
on the left because
for the left politics is not about using
reason
with great deference to the tradition
and our forefathers
to understand justice and how to live
together for the left politics is all
about
interests as far as i can tell there are
four
ways that they can attack amy coney
barrett
and the most beautiful thing about her
nomination is all of these
ultimately fall flat but there are four
ways i've been analyzing all of the
attacks on her
first one is to call her dangerous
this is this is the kavanaugh the
kavanaugh attack is to say
that this person who seems perfectly
polite and nice and milk toast and
you know if anything maybe a little bit
boring you know at dinner parties
that this person is actually a criminal
a thug
dangerous they're going to attack you
you won't feel safe this is what ayanna
presley the ringo
of the squad you know it's aoc and the
other ones and then ayanna presley's
kind of the
not not as prominent member of the squad
she used this line of attack she said
quote
barret is dangerous and unfit to serve
on the highest court
the appellate judge mom of seven
whose worst and most controversial
vice according to the popular culture is
that she prays too much that's what they
say they actually say like the worst
thing this woman does
is she prays a lot and goes to church
and
is part of a christian group that
woman's dangerous
are you afraid of that woman you've
we've all seen pictures now of amy coney
bear and she's actually been a little
bit of a
political celebrity for a few years now
since her name was floated last time
now obviously she's a worldwide
well-known celebrity
she looked ner did she make you nervous
does she look scary to you does she look
dangerous
when you see her seven children five
biological
two adopted husband all smiling
all happy does that seem dangerous to
you i don't think so that one's gonna
completely fall flat
because it just so strains credulity
there's no way to convince anybody that
this
mild-mannered midwestern mom who goes to
church a lot
that she's dangerous number two attack
is to attack her judicial philosophy
so this is one of the usual tax it was
the one that they used
when they first started this acrimonious
supreme court confirmation process going
all the way back to ted kennedy
and judge bork and and uh then moving
later throughout the 80s and and really
then it shifts in the 90s but the first
attack on judge bork you'll remember
was not on his personal life didn't call
him a rapist didn't call him dangerous
ted kennedy in the 80s said that judge
borg's judicial philosophy
was terrible for black people and women
and all
sorts of people but it was an attack on
originalism on the ideas
not on the person then you get into
clarence thomas and
joe biden's hearings of clarence thomas
then it became again he's a rapist he's
a dangerous person he's a terrible
person but before that it was the
judicial philosophy so how does amy
coney bear going to do
leaning right into it i was lucky enough
to clerk for justice scalia
and given his incalculable influence on
my life
i am very moved to have members of the
scalia family here today
including his dear wife maureen
i clerked for justice scalia more than
20 years ago
but the lessons i learned still resonate
his judicial philosophy is mine too
a judge must apply the law as written
judges are not policy makers and they
must be resolute and setting aside any
policy views they might hold
she's a scalia originalist i i had the
privilege of meeting
scalia twice when i was a student and he
described his political
or his judicial philosophy rather as
being different
than partisanship as being different
than
interests and and the one maybe defining
feature of
scalia's originalism is when he said if
you're a really good originalist judge
you will not always be happy with the
decisions that you end up with
meaning i have this personal interest i
have this political preference
but if i'm actually applying originalism
then sometimes what the constitution and
the law actually say
are different than what i would prefer
that they say
if i were a legislator for instance when
bork
was up for the court it was all too new
this idea of applying the law fairly
this idea of reading the constitution
and figuring out what it actually means
not just what we would like it to mean
it was too new and so they got rid of
him but scalia has done such a great job
of explaining originalism over the years
that that is now the mainstream
conservative legal philosophy
and so amy coney barrett comes out there
and says that's my philosophy
that's not going to be controversial it
is now
at least it's at least acceptable
in illegal circles to say i'm not going
to push my partisan interest i'm not
going to legislate from the bench
i am interested in justice you know
what's
unjust paying too much for your cell
phone bill oh my gosh
amy coney barrett with such a great
setup on
that ad my friends at puretalk usa can
help you here when you're overpaying for
your cell phone
i'm going to be extremely blunt about
this because i think people don't
understand what i'm saying
let's say your cell phone plan is with
verizon att
t-mobe you're paying way too much
for the exact same coverage that you'll
be getting
with pure talk not similar coverage i'm
not saying it's like they use
towers that are kind of similar to the
other it's the
exact same coverage you're just paying
maybe twice as much the average person
who switches to pure talk is using less
than four gigs of data a month
the big carriers are charging you for
unlimited data that's like
paying for an entire row on an airplane
and then you just need one seat
that's not very smart financial decision
that's how pure talk saves the average
person over 400
a year on their wireless service
unlimited talk
text two gigs of data you get it all for
just 20 bucks
per month get your mobile phone right
now right now well maybe not right now
if you're driving or something i don't
know but
very quickly grab your mobile phone dial
pound 250
and say michael knowles when you do you
will save 50
off your first month dial pound or
hashtag
that's the modern that's a cool new
modern way to say it hashtag
250 say keyword michael knowles puretalk
simply smarter
wireless so the judicial philosophy is
out there that is now mainstream i'm not
saying the left likes it i'm not saying
they're not going to still
try to go after the judicial nominees
actually the judicial philosophy
is ultimately what they're after but
they're not open about that anymore
so she leans right into it she says yep
i'm with scalia i'm an originalist
nothing really to criticize or scare
monger over yet until she gets
to her family and and acb
goes straight from her judicial
philosophy
into her family structure sounds
wonderful sends wholesome how on earth
could you attack her for it
the democrats find a way the president
has asked me to become the ninth justice
and as it happens i'm used to being in a
group of nine
my family
our family includes me my husband jesse
emma vivian tess gent peter
liam juliet and benjamin
vivian and john peter as the president
said were born in haiti and they came to
us
five years apart when they were very
young and the most revealing fact about
benjamin
our youngest is that his brothers and
sisters unreservedly identify him as
their favorite sibling our children
obviously make our life very full
while i am a judge i'm better known back
home as a room parent
carpool driver and birthday party
planner
when schools went remote last spring i
tried on another
hat jessie and i became co-principals of
the barrett e-learning academy
and yes the list of enrolled students
was a very long one
our children are my greatest joy even
though they deprive me of any reasonable
amount of sleep
so they try to attack her as dangerous
that's not going to work they try to
attack her philosophy the people aren't
going to buy that anymore
i know what you're thinking you see
there's no way they're going to go after
her
family she's got this beautiful family
she's got this wonderful story
she and her husband have an apparently
very nice marriage
five biological kids they adopt two kids
from haiti everybody gets along it's so
wonderful what a beautiful thing to do
the left is attacking her for it they
are
there is this this i guess now somewhat
famous maybe
infamous anti-racist author
and diversity consultant ibrahim kendi
now maybe you've heard this name abram
kennedy's come up a lot in the blm stuff
it should be clear when you hear these
terms anti-racist author or
diversity consultant what that really
means is
con artist means fraud that's that's all
he is this guy is a complete huckster
who is scamming people out of money he's
technically a professor of boston
university's founding director of the
boston university center for anti-racist
research what is anti-racist research
what
what academic discipline is that part of
none he's a contributor for
the atlantic and the cbs news
correspondent so he's just another
leftist media hack and
even on the academic front you say okay
well he's a professor right he's got to
be a real academic right
he's not he has a phd in something
called african-american studies
which is a fake academic discipline just
like all the other
critical studies disciplines they're not
real they have they have nothing to do
with actual scholarship or actual
academic disciplines
they are ideology in the university
that's all they do they just
take a very shallow modern ideological
view
and they make an entire academic
department out of it but it's not it's
not academic it's pseudo-academic
obviously the study of ideology has
something to do
in a university but typically you would
study that through
philosophy right that would that's an
actual academic discipline
or even history how these different
ideologies have cropped up
but the ideology itself is not an
academic discipline it's just too
shallow there's not enough scholarly
meat there
and so this guy has a fake phd he writes
for a couple hack
outlets he's the founding director of
some
fake academic center at boston
university and he milks people out of
money as a diversity consultant
he's an enti he's a scam artist and then
he has the goal to attack this woman's
family he says some white colonizers
adopted black children they civilized
these savage children in the superior
ways of white people
while using them as props and their
lifelong pictures of denial while
cutting the biological parents of these
children
out of the picture of humanity
adopting poor kids orphans
from from bad areas
is now a bad thing now of course it's
not and what he's saying by the way is
white people shouldn't adopt black
people right that's that's what's lying
at the bottom of what he's saying
and he's the professor of anti-racism
makes you think huh maybe this
anti-racism thing
isn't really what it what it sounds like
maybe this anti-fascism thing isn't
really
really what it sounds like this is i
mean
there's no reason to ever listen to this
guy he's a total fraud
and and what he says is worth less than
nothing but
the reason i point it out is because
it's a very bad look for democrats
he's saying what a lot of them are
thinking but a lot of
professional democrats you know elected
people operatives
they realize this is going to be a bad
line of attack i don't think it's going
to play in peoria
people are not going to like it when you
attack this woman's children
and attack this woman for adopting
children from
a bad place you know in a bad situation
and giving them a loving home and
raising them and bringing them to the
land of the free
if you attack a woman for that uh not
going to be a good look in november
so this brings us then to the fourth
attack first two they can't lob the
third one they do lob but it looks
really bad the fourth one
is attacking her religion you know
dianne feinstein already did this
said that the dogma lives loudly within
amy coney barrett because she's a
catholic
same thing dick durbin said the city
goes what you actually believe
catholicism you're orthodox and you're
in your religion that's so weird what
i've never heard of that before
and then bill maher put it in less
polite terms
but apparently the pick is going to be
this omi
omi amy comey will all
be saying this name a lot i'm sure
because she's a nut
religion i was right about that one too
amy sorry but
amy comey barrett catholic really
catholic
i mean really really catholic like
speaking in tongues like
she doesn't believe in condoms which is
what she has in common with trump
because he doesn't need it
also a terrible look for democrats first
of all
when bill maher speaks doesn't he just
remind you of that
like smug 13 year old you knew in middle
school
who who whose arguments for atheism were
more or less
um i can't see god where is he i can't
touch him
checkmate theists yeah um
if god is real then uh
why why won't he manifest himself
physically when i demand it
um checkmate christians it's just
so shallow it's as if
as if people hadn't been thinking of
these questions before as if
saint thomas aquinas never existed as if
the summa theologia didn't exist if
saint augustine didn't exist
as if the great geniuses of history the
great doctors of the church
because then bill maher comes and says
wait a second
i can't see god or whatever his dumb
arguments are
you say oh my okay well you're right
there goes my summa theologia time to
set it on fire
even think about uh pope pope benedict
xvi pope emeritus benedict xvi
maybe the greatest living theologian a
brilliant scholar who has been writing
and thinking about
god for his entire life
who do you think has a better handle on
these things who do you think
has more brain cells rubbing together
who do you think has spent
more time in serious contemplation of
this question pope benedict
or bill maher and yet bill maher with
the arrogance that only a true leftist
can muster
says it's so ridiculous i don't even
need to consider this question
i know sometimes bill maher says things
we like so we say he's not on the left
but he is on the left
he just he likes telling dirty jokes too
so he's not totally politically correct
but that's not a good argument you
remember about
a week ago when democrats were saying
that joe biden is a devout catholic and
how wonderful it is to be a devout
catholic
we said no he's not he was actually
refused communion because he's
he's in a state of grave scandal and
he's supporting
abortion on demand taxpayer funded up
until the moment of birth so
he actually he's not he's he's not in
good standing right now
with the catholic church and they say
he's devout how dare you but now you get
an actual calf like an actual practicing
catholic
and they say she's an effing nut
this leaves only one option for
democrats
one option which the smart ones you're
taking
it's the only safe option and speaking
of safety you need to make sure that no
one steals your information on the
internet you do you have got to be very
responsible right now because
people are working from home people are
doing your school from home and
the cyber criminals know that and
they're going to try to steal your
identity identity theft is a big
time crime there are whole criminal
gangs operating units dedicated to it
it's very important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft
affect our lives every day we put our
information
on the internet right you could miss
certain identity threats
if you're just monitoring your credit
that's why you need a life lock
which detects a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web this one in
particular
if they detect your information they
will send you an
alert now no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can find out if your information
is out there on the dark web you can
find that out right now and you should
because it can cause a lot of headaches
down the road get your free dark web
scan
at lifelock.com knowles canadawlas pick
the plan that's right for you save up to
25
off your first year with promo code
noles i rely on these guys
uh i'm now totally i used to think no
one's after my data they are people are
after your stuff
i wouldn't go on the internet without
this kind of protection there's a free
scan
at lifelock.com knowles can w les
25 off with promo code knowles
can't call her dangerous can't go after
her judicial philosophy
they are going after her family and it
doesn't look good they are going after
her religion and it doesn't look good
there's one thing left they can do and
that is
retreat they can retreat they can run
away from this
because there's no way that this works
well for democrats
attacking amy coney bear hearings
tentatively scheduled for october 12th
the democrats are planning to boycott at
least some
democrats are planning to boycott two
senators maisie hirono and richard
blumenthal
say that they will not meet with amy
coney bear beforehand they haven't said
that they won't meet with her
if the hearings take place but they're
saying they're not even going to sit
down with her beforehand because it
would quote
legitimize president trump's decision to
nominate
the glorious acb i think this is
democrats best
chance is to just not show up to the
hearings do you remember what kavanaugh
did to the democrats
do you remember what that did it gave us
such a boost
it so helped republicans and it will do
that again in november
and i'm even willing to give this free
advice to democrats one because i like
i'd like to call it like i see it even
if i don't want to let the secrets out
for the democrats
but two they're not going to be able to
resist
democratic senators senators of any kind
cannot resist a tv camera
they always say this about chuck schumer
the most dangerous place in new york
is between chuck schumer and a tv camera
right you can't they can't resist the
cameras
they're going to have to do it and it's
going to look really bad because as we
pointed out every line of attack they
have on this woman
is going to hurt them now
amy coney barrett is not just changing
up the democrats election strategy with
regard to say hearings or public
appearances
she's she's completely changing
their electoral strategy in november the
nomination is changing everything and
nobody's talking about this
so the strategy previously was promote
mail-in ballots
hire a lot of lawyers challenge the
results of the election
on election night there's going to be a
red mirage trump is going to win on
election night but then you're going to
get enough lawyers to challenge the
results
and wait for the mail ends and maybe
find a few boxes of melons i don't know
hiding out somewhere and then bring it
all the way up to the courts and then at
the supreme court they're going to give
it to the democrats
that was the strategy but now
they can't rely on the supreme court
because the most
stalwart partisan democratic
judge on the supreme court is no longer
there they cannot rely on ruth ginsburg
so now they've got to change their
strategy
they've got to pull the election back
out of the courts and if they're going
to pull the election back out of the
courts and actually try to win it fair
and square at the ballot box
then they're going to have to back down
on pushing for widespread mail-in
and they're going to have to back down
and refusing to concede the election
this is not some wild crazy conspiracy
theory okay
they actually told us they were going to
do this do you remember a couple weeks
ago when hillary clinton said
joe biden should not under any
circumstances concede the election
do you remember that and then they
attacked donald trump for not respecting
the results of the election they did
this in 2016 too
hillary said trump's not respecting the
results of the election and then what
happened she loses and she doesn't
respect the results of the election
so she comes out and says it and a lot
of democrats cheered her on
well now they're realizing goodness
gracious if we can't even rely on the
court to steal this election for us
maybe we should back off that plan dick
durbin second highest ranking democratic
senator senate minority whip
came out on abc talking to george
stephanopoulos who
is a former employee of the clintons and
said
i disagree with hillary i disagree with
hillary clinton
uh i respect her i like her but i think
she just flat out wrong
the the election itself is going to be
announced the winner will be announced
at some point it'll take
longer with all the paper ballots that
are being cast but at some point
i hope my choice joe biden is elected
president
but if we are going to maintain a
democracy peaceful transition through an
election is the only way to do it
great i'm so glad to hear that you've
changed your mind dick i'm so glad to
hear
after hearing democrats tell me for
weeks that they were not going to
concede
at all even if trump won i'm so pleased
to hear that now you'll respect the
results of this
election but it's not just debt they're
also backing off of the widespread
mail-in votes so you remember
democrats had been pushing for everybody
to use mail-in
almost every single person they were
expecting 80 to 100 million
mail-in votes this election that was
in part because they said covet is so
dangerous you can't possibly show up to
the polls on election day
it's outrageous to expect people to show
up to the polls they can and should show
up to blm
riots all over the country but that's
that's okay because covet doesn't spread
there
they just can't go to the polls because
that's where you get coveted
we know that mail-in voting
is rife with fraud how do we know this
well there was an experiment done
by a news affiliate in philadelphia they
mailed in 100
mail-in ballots dummy mail-in ballots
they mailed it to a p.o box what
happened
uh they got two birthday cards in the
mailboxes somewhere the wires got
crossed
they took days and days so much longer
than anyone expected
to to get the mail and then by the end
of it three of them were missing
three percent guess what sway is an
election three percent
we know that we've seen examples of
voter fraud going on in new jersey in
particular recently
we saw news reports coming out of texas
kaylee mcinnady white house press
secretary gave us examples
of voting fraud and voting
irregularities just
last week the president wants to get rid
of
mass mail out voting and that's not
because it he said clearly that that
could go either way it could damage
either candidates
chances because it's a system that's
subject to fraud in fact in the last
24 hours police in greenville wisconsin
found
mail in a ditch and it included absentee
ballots
and also i can confirm for you that
trump ballots
um ballots for the president were found
in pennsylvania and i believe you should
be getting more information on that
shortly here in the last
24 hours they were found cast aside so
weird because we're being told by
everybody that there is no problem with
mail-in ballot there's no problem with
widespread mail and there's no evidence
that widespread mail-in in any way leads
to fraud now first of all what
that statement is in a sense a truism
because we've never
had widespread mail in ballots like this
so of course there's no
prior evidence this is a new political
strategy but moreover
what do you say about the trump ballots
that were found to have gone missing and
showed up a little bit later what do you
say about that in
in pennsylvania whoopsie daisy
that well that's that's undeniable what
do you say about the box of ballots that
was found in a ditch somewhere
what do you say about that and what's
going to happen in all of the counties
in all of the states around the country
so what changed why are they now
completely shifting their argument on
malen
is it covid did something change with
kovid did the virus mutate i don't think
so
they just know that they can no longer
rely on the supreme court
to give them the election there is one
way
there is one way that the democrats are
trying now
to sway public opinion on
amy coney barrett it's not necessarily
an attack on her
it's not talking about the big issue
that we're all talking about roe versus
wade and abortion
it's not talking about that there is one
way
that the democrats are going to try to
do it it's a it's a traditional election
strategy they've been using it for 30
years
i still think it's not going to work we
will find out in just one second first
got to thank our friends over at rad
power bikes you know the weather is
pretty nice outside today
at least it is over here where i am you
might want to try to take
advantage of it with rad power bikes
whether you want a new way to get around
town or you want to get out in nature
even with the kids in tow you've got to
try
rad power bikes rad power bikes is a
cross between a traditional bike
and a moped here's the key though it
doesn't require a special driver's
license like a moped
would so you can go up to 20 miles an
hour without pedaling
you can get out and about without
getting sweaty rad power bikes are
affordable
most e-bikes are in the 3 000 range
rad power bikes start at just 999
dollars
most of them are under 1500 they're
really really high-end stuff a great way
to take advantage
of the lovely weather and getting around
i i love this sort of thing dedicated us
based customer service
customer support seven days a week will
answer any questions or concerns
that you have makes the perfect gift for
someone who loves being active and
outdoors and i have to tell you when i'm
traveling around town especially even
when i'm traveling around cities or
suburbs
i love these bikes because you can you
can get around so easily it's so
efficient
check them out right now can't recommend
it highly enough rad power bikes offer
flexible financing for as low as zero
percent apr
now for a limited time get a free
accessory valued
at up to a hundred dollars with the
purchase of a bike
okay that is a free gift of up to 100 in
value with your purchase
free shipping to the lower 48 states to
get this special offer text the word
knowles to 64 thousand that is canada
wlas to 64 000 text knowles to 64 000
right now
just find out get that sweet deal also
tomorrow night is fight night
are you ready 9 pm eastern 6 pm pacific
donald trump and joe biden face off in
the first of three
presidential debates will joe biden fall
asleep will donald trump wear a mask
join us
for an all-new episode of daily wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major political event and better
join daily wire now as an insider all
access member
get 20 off with code debate so you can
watch all the debate coverage live on
our apple tv or roku app they are
putting us
on the big screen and you will get not
one but two leftist tiers tumblers with
your membership as well as early and
sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products dailywire.com
right now
you will get 20 off with the code debate
we'll be right back with a lot more
the issue that democrats always
demagogue is healthcare
that's the one they keep coming back to
and they keep coming back to healthcare
because there's no answer to it there's
no answer
it's obviously disingenuous and
ridiculous do you remember how obamacare
was supposed to solve our healthcare
problems once and for all that's how it
was sold to us they said
look one big fix it's going to be very
expensive it's going to totally change
healthcare system but then we'll have
fixed healthcare in america
and it's all good except it wasn't
because we got obamacare and then they
still complained about and the uninsured
and
this and that and this and that and the
promises of obamacare were lies
if you like your doctor you can keep
your doctor i think that was the
politifact lie of the year that year
and it was a rare occasion where
politifact actually hit a democrat
so that one was out how about premiums
will go down they didn't go down they
went up
it was a total lie but they always
demagogue it because democrats can
always push
a bigger and bigger plan to take more
and more power
over the fundamental question of life
and death from people
right that's what that's why the
democrats always move into health care
that's why they move into education too
if you control education you're shaping
the future of the country
if you control health care then you
control questions of life and death
so they push wealth care and what's the
republican answer there isn't one
because the republican answer is
i think we should have more of a
decentralized system with a little more
consumer choice and
focus on quality and make sure we take
care of the people who are in need which
we already have by the way
nobody is told that they have to die in
the street in the united states
this idea they say what about the poor
what are the we already have so many
healthcare programs for the poor
medic medicare for elderly people
medicaid
for poor people we've got
the children's health insurance plan
we've got this health insurance plan we
get that health insurance plan
it's never enough though because they
always say what you want people to die
so it's a good one to demagogue on
and that's the only way they're going to
try to sway public opinion about amy
coney barrett and how are they going to
relate amy coney barrett
to health care hillary clinton speaking
with joy reid at the
texas tribune festival with msnbc
made the public relations pitch and she
did it in exactly those terms
she was saying these are the talking
points that we need to be on
ultimately this fight it seems to me
is about health care remember health
care
is literally before the court
trump and the republicans led by mitch
mcconnell have been trying to get rid of
health care
for years ever since president obama
passed
the affordable care act for reasons that
escape me
they want to strip away the rights of
people with pre-existing conditions
about 130 million americans
from getting affordable health care they
want to totally take away the
coverage for 22 million americans who
get their health care
through the affordable care act they
want to take away all the protections
that were passed
by the congress like being 26 and still
being able to stay on your
uh parents policy and the list goes on
so let's be sure we understand that what
the republicans
are doing is rushing an appointment
to the court to repeal the affordable
care act and strip away health care from
many
millions of americans that's the issue
is it hillary now of course she gives
away the game in that language there she
says they want to repeal the affordable
care act
courts don't repeal things they can
overturn decisions they can rule
that certain laws are unconstitutional
and that that's always been the issue
with obamacare
the issue with obamacare in the courts
is not whether the courts like obamacare
or not it's not whether they like that
particular health care plan or this
particular health care plan
it's is the plan constitutional can the
federal government force you to buy a
product from a private company
and in the original obamacare decision
john roberts the chief justice decided
that he was going to try to have his
cake and eat it too and say
well the individual mandate of obamacare
is a tax
for for this reason but it's a penalty
for this reason and
therefore it's constitutional it was so
ridiculous scalia made mincemeat of his
stupid opinion
but he was just doing it basically to
give the libs a win because he felt that
people would revolt and burn down the
supreme court if he if he
overturned and deemed unconstitutional
obamacare
but that's the issue it's not about
legislation and do republicans really we
want to take health care away from
millions and millions of people is that
really what happened is that really what
you believe hillary
no of course not but they are making
that pitch
because they they think that they can
tie health care
to abortion really what this amy coney
barrett thinks about is what all of the
supreme court
nominations have been about going all
the way back to judge bork and it's what
that one was about too
abortion because of this stupid decision
roe versus wade
that invented a fictional constitutional
right to abortion
get your magnifying glass out look at
the constitution find me the right to an
abortion you
won't find it it's nowhere and the
people who wrote that stupid decision
roe versus wade
didn't even pretend they didn't even try
to say they found it
they said there were penumbras and
emanations and this and then if you look
secretly in the invisible ink
it's all bs they felt that it they
needed
their for the social upheaval of the
country
they just wanted there to be a right to
an abortion and so they made it up at a
pole cloth and they know it's
indefensible
and honest liberal jurists will tell you
that it's indefensible
and that's why all of these decisions
have been so contentious that's why all
these confirmations
have been so contentious hillary admits
it she says look
without mentioning abortion she says
this health care issue
that's the case we've got to make if we
want to hold up
this nomination there is no mistake
about that you know there are other
issues that we'll look at down the road
but
right now the democrats need to make
that case
there are other issues that will look
out down the road sure but right now the
case the democrats have to make is about
health care
why because you know that if you if you
hold up this woman who's
very attractive she's very attractive in
her resume she's
she's physically attractive she's
attractive as a nominee she's attractive
constitutionally
if you hold up this nominee over your
maniacal sociopathic obsession with
killing babies
that's not going to look great for the
2020 presidential election
so you got to pretend that this is all
about health care when it's actually
about the opposite of health care
it's actually about killing people it
couldn't be more opposite
for health care and and hillary clinton
describes the republican efforts to do
what the constitution requires an
appointed judge
she describes them in religious terms
but not
not the good religion not in the bright
light heavenly terms she describes it in
hellish terms
this could not be more diabolical and i
think that
democrats need to be absolutely clear
at the federal level in this fight with
mcconnell and trump but also
in the senate races that any vote for
any republican
is literally a vote to cost you money uh
to make your health care
more expensive and maybe to eliminate
the possibility you'll be able to afford
it
at all anyone else notice how happy
hillary clinton looked when she said the
word diabolical
she goes yes it's uh it's really
it's diabolical oh wow
she's sort of stirring whatever is in
her cauldron
uh yeah hillary clinton certainly
certainly gets a thrill by that word
diabolical but diabolical is a good word
to use not for what the republicans are
doing but for what the democrats are
doing you don't need to take my word for
it take the word of the huffington post
woman writing for the huffington post
jamie smith writes
the death of justice ruth bader ginsburg
pushed me to join
the satanic temple
there's a picture of like baphomet or
something some kind of satanic symbol
i'm a 40-something attorney and mother
who lives in a quiet neighborhood with a
yard and a garage full of scooters and
soccer balls
i'm not the type of person who would
normally consider becoming a satanist
but these are not normal times are they
not
are they not normal i actually think
these are normal times we always say
we're living in such crazy times i mean
they're interesting times
but the times are interesting generally
life isn't the world is very interesting
and i i have to disagree with this woman
i think that she's exactly the type of
person
who would become a satanist the type of
person
who thinks she doesn't really
have strong religious views she actually
says here that the satanic temple
they're atheists
it's not like they're they're believing
in some spiritual thing they're actually
atheists they don't think god exists
they don't think the spiritual world
exists okay
but they just think these damn
republicans are so crazy they're
they're they're theocrats they're
they're awful and we should all be
afraid she says i fear that american
citizens are inching closer to living in
a theocracy or a dictatorship
and that the checks meant to prevent
this from happening are close to eroding
fundamental despair
and the satanic temple they just believe
in fundamental tenets
such as the struggle for justice is an
ongoing and necessary pursuit
that should prevail over laws and
institutions and that one's body is
inviolable subject to one's will
alone and you know these are things that
we believe plenty of people believe in
them
this is exactly how satanism operates
you think a satanist is just like scary
people in robes doing all sorts of
things
no no the greatest trick the devil ever
played
was convincing people that he does not
exist
that's always how the devil has operated
the greatest trick
that the devil has up his sleeve the
greatest temptation is to distract you
with the things of this world
don't need to take my word for it that's
the gospel truth
to distract you to tempt you with things
such as power
which is what this woman is talking
about or filling your physical desires
or indulging your appetites
christ's temptation by the devil in the
wilderness is that
right that's that is how it operates and
when we use these terms
diabolical or these are they really are
getting at something
don't you think it's a little weird that
all of these people who are
who come from i guess different
backgrounds different geographical
backgrounds different political
backgrounds
all the political issues on the table
the one that is holding them up
the one that is going to create this
chaos for the supreme court nomination
is whether or not we have the right to
kill a million babies
this should not this is not a
complicated issue the issue of abortion
is not complicated we pretend it's
complicated there's a new movie out
on hbo max called unpregnant i'll do a
review of it coming up
but it's about it's like a buddy trip
about going out and killing a bunch of
babies
this is not a complicated issue do you
think a country should allow
its citizens to kill a million babies a
year
no nobody thinks so then there are all
these tricks they say well it's not
really a baby it's not really human
not really alive yeah it's all of those
things it's very clearly all of them i
have a sonogram i can show you
i can show you that it's all of those
things forget about even the
philosophical arguments which are all
very clear
don't you think that's a weird
coincidence that's like an odd thing
wouldn't shouldn't we be arguing about
taxes or foreign policy or
or actual health care or that no
because these diabolical
influences these diabolical people these
people actually joining the satanic
temple
they know not what they do there's a big
political endorsement that just came out
big meaning that the person who endorsed
is very big he's one of the biggest
muscular people in the world
his name is the rock the rock who i
always heard was a kind of moderate
republican
he's endorsing joe biden and he's
endorsing joe biden
in the stupidest political endorsement i
have ever heard
take a listen to the rock's reasoning
you know look i've got friends in all
parties but the one thing that we can
always agree on
is the conversation and the dialogue and
where that conversation lands
is always the most critical part now
this is something that i've certainly
not done in the past
so i'm gonna go big you guys know me if
i go
i go big so guys i had the opportunity
to sit down
with vice president joe biden and
senator kamala harris to talk about
a number of important issues that we're
facing as a country
i thought it was a great and extremely
productive conversation that we
had and as a registered independent for
years now with
census centrist excuse me ideologies
i do feel that vice president biden and
senator harris
are the best choice to lead our country
and i am endorsing them to become
president
and vice president of our united states
the rock is endorsing biden and harris
because he likes
conversation now first of all
which party right now do you think is
encouraging conversation
dialogue civil discourse is it the one
nominating a supreme court justice and
calling for hearings and debate over
that
or is it the one burning down the
country burning
rioting looting killing people
encouraging all of that which one do you
think it is
the democrats are not permitting
conversation
of any kind they are censoring people
they are de-platforming people they are
physically intimidating people with
violence if they say things
that they don't like or don't say things
that they do like that image of that mob
screaming say black lives matter say blm
say is that screaming at that woman in
the restaurant you remember that a few
weeks ago
they don't even believe the conversation
can exist because
the left is now saying that we can't
getting right back to the top of the
show we can't be impartial there's no
such thing
as objective justice objective reality
there's just
subjective experience my lived
experience which you can't talk about
and i can't talk about your lived
experience so you got to shut up
and politics is not about the rational
pursuit
of truth that is outside of ourselves
which is essential to communication
because when we communicate we're just
using symbols which are called words
and i say one symbol and you hear that
symbol and if there's not something
outside of both of us to which that
symbol refers
then it can't mean anything right
they're saying yeah none of that can
exist it's just
my interests it's just my feeling the
only thing i can know is real
is my suffering and you can't know
anything about that so just on the
philosophical point not that i think
that
the rock is the greatest living
philosopher
what he's saying doesn't make any sense
but secondly enough conversation
i like conversation as much as the next
guy i like it a lot more than the left
does
conversation is not an end unto itself
conversation is a means to an end we
don't
we we don't engage in conversation
without a purpose
idle chatter is not conversation
grunting and noise is not conversation
the purpose of conversation
is to get a little closer to the truth
to dust off the truth to see things more
clearly to come to an understanding of
something
there is a purpose there is an end to
conversation in a civil society
conversation
is about dusting off the truth a little
bit persuading our fellow citizens to
see the truth as we see it
and then governing ourselves that's the
purpose of it
if you're not doing that if you're
writing off half the country is
deplorable and irredeemable if you're
writing off
the possibility of conversation the
possibility of justice the
possibility of impartiality and
objective truth
then there's no purpose to that
conversation
we hear that we hear that sort of
nonsense so much
from the left-wingers they don't believe
it themselves they don't believe
in the ability to persuade one another
to have reason
to converse and so without that and even
with that
we have to pursue discrete ends it's not
just about the form of politics
we have to have substance it's not just
about the form of having the judge
the judge has to be able to read the
constitution and when we're talking
about substantive moral claims
we have to realize that killing a
million babies a year is bad
you think you'd be able to say that in a
country there's a difference between
notorious rgb and glorious acb there's a
difference between those things
i love by the way they're very upset
that now conservatives are using the
phrase notorious acb or we've changed it
to gloria's acb
because we're they're saying that we
stole that from rbg
as if biggie smalls didn't exist is it
do you remember you know
she took that from regardless there's a
difference do we want to be notorious do
we want to be glorious
do we want to kill a million babies a
year do we want to not kill a million
babies a year
do we want to live in a country where
our governance is defined by rioting and
looting and violence or do we want to
live in a country
with civility we want to live in a
country where we are
civilized people and can discuss and
govern ourselves
that's the choice the rock made the
wrong choice for the wrong reasons
the rest of the choice is up to us and i
have to tell you the
outlook as we we look at the next two
months has just become
much more glorious i'm michael knowles
the michael noel show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. you know the matt wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture
because culture drives politics and it
drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen